make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering beta ray bill
God hunter and the reason we're covering
this is after finishing Thor issue
number three a lot of people were asking
about the history that we had kind of
discussed between beta ray bill and
Galactus like why beta ray bill hates
Galactus so much and so I figured we'd
cover this right I mean the stories out
there so instead of just being like once
upon a time in this video that has
nothing to do with this story uh this
story happened and then let's move on
now instead of doing that I figure we
will go ahead and and actually cover the
story itself right so a couple things to
know the first is the origin of beta ray
bill and the second is why we basically
have this story in the first place as
most of you guys know by doing your own
research probably either because of what
we've talked about or when the whole
news was dropped about Christian Bale
possibly playing beta ray bill the idea
is that Bill is part of a race called
the korbinites but he's basically a
cyborg right he was engineered for the
purpose of protecting the korbinite race
after they left their planet when it was
destroyed by Serdar and his forces and
so ultimately they ended up just kind of
being a nomadic race had just traveled
from one location to the next for quite
some time now along the way the ships
scuttlebutt and the korbinites had
stumbled across earth which led to Thor
basically being set out to investigate
by Nick Fury and that's when bill was
activated that's when you got the
original appearance of beta ray bill in
Marvel Comics and then a kind of
camaraderie was formed between the two
groups after that now later on down the
line and actually in a story called a
storm breaker the saga of beta ray bill
beta ray bill ends up finding a new home
called new Korbin for the korbinite race
they end up settling there and then
Galactus shows up it's like the worst of
luck ever right like we finally found
our home oh my god Glocke he's gonna
destroy our world and basically it
happened when beta ray bill was actually
off planet but he wasn't and he wasn't
on new Korbin at the time and so this
basically took place as part of a new
Herald named Stardust coming on board
and so during that story essentially
Galactus consumed and destroyed the
world of new Korbin basically leaving
beta ray bill as the last of the
korbinites and so because that he's kind
of sort of had in the back of his mind
this idea of going on a campaign to take
out Galactus right to rid the universe
of Galactus for what it was that he'd
done and that's why he's here talking to
Thor because the idea is to get Thor to
come along now the response of Thor is
interesting here and it actually makes
sense but we also sort of have to
understand what's going on with this
character at the time
at this point in Thor's comic book
continuity he's been banished from
Asgard and the reason why comes out of
four issues six hundred and six hundred
and one by J michael Straczynski kind of
the ending of his Thor one and the idea
was that Loki had basically found a way
to bring Bohr to the modern age right
now Bohr of course is the father of Odin
the grandfather of Thor and at the end
of that story
basically Bohr ended up killing bored
but because of the fact that he had
killed a king of Asgard the price for
doing that is banishment regardless of
what the motivations of Bohr were or any
of that and so with that in mind this
basically led to Thor in his current
place where his power is a little bit
reduced and so even if he did want to
join beta evil he really wouldn't be
able to do a whole lot there but there
wouldn't be a whole lot that he could
offer in this particular circumstance
and so as a result of that you end up
having beta ray bill who basically
undertakes the mission on his own and
the first person he visits is Abigail
brand now those are guys who are not
familiar with her character we'll go
ahead and explain it here if you are
familiar bear with me for a second but
Abigail brand at least if you're going
to read Marvel Comics right now Alpha
Flight at least I'm not really familiar
with Captain Marvel I don't have a
router comics for a little while but I
believe she's still the head of Alpha
Flight before her it was Abigail brand
and it wasn't really even called Alpha
Flight it was just called sword the
sentient world observation and response
department and it operated on a space
station called the peak now Abigail
brand was introduced as part of Joss
Whedon's run on astonishing x-men in the
first volume and the reason why she's
the the head of sword is because if
sword is an organization like shield
except it exists to monitor other
extraterrestrial planets and races and
so on and so forth out in space and then
Abigail brand was the perfect choice for
it because she has the ability to
basically speak and understand every
language in existence right and so
because of that she's the one that
basically runs the show here now as part
of Marvel I guess all-new all-different
marvel or whatever was Carol Danvers
ended up taking over as director of
sword and then rebranded it into alpha
flight and then Abigail brand Oliva know
what she's doing anymore I have no clue
but regardless the reason why beta
rebuilds here is because Abigail brand
would know or at least have some rumor
Ang's on where Galactus has been sighted
right because wild she's not able to
keep a perfect eye on him because the
resources of sword are finite meaning
they can't really see to the other side
of the universe but basically like
Galactus was sighted in this location
like three days ago
now he is given a bit of a mission to
track down a guy by the name of void II
and he's not really important right like
vodiane appeared as part of the Secret
Invasion
aftermath a story called the garden Eden
I thing as
it was basically he ended up traveling
to this place where you had this race
called the remnants who were like
anybody who wants to come hang out is
welcome he reprogrammed a whole bunch of
him he said he was here to bring
annihilation or whatever it is and then
told them to go build some God in the
pocket dimension or something on those
lines and that was it right I mean the
guy was nowhere he was not very
important at all but he is on the swords
radar and sword is you know asking beta
ray bill to bring him in and really his
involvement here is just for the sake of
this story it doesn't really matter but
you end up having beta ray bill who
shows up here and absolutely starts
wrecking the whole place and then you
have basically him taking 40 and hostage
and that's basically it from there you
jump to a planet called Ethan I think is
how it's pronounced I'm not really sure
if it's an L or an i or anyway it's the
ninth planet in the system and the
result is that basically you have
Stardust here as a Herald of Galactus
essentially saying like Galactus is
coming he's going to consume everything
and then you have the starships who
basically flee now this was a big
difference between Stardust in like the
Silver Surfer
for example the Stardust believes but
it's one of these things were like it's
an honor for a race to die at the hands
of Galactus and have their world
consumed for silver surfer it was if we
can find an uninhabited world that can
sustain life will consume that but if
there is life on that world
at least give me time to allow them to
get off the world that Stardust wasn't
really that way Stardust was a lot more
intense and a lot more hardcore than
Silver Surfer was and so tracking down
Galactus to this location ultimately
beta ray bill jumps in and basically
save some of this race they keep them
from being killed and then basically
buys in the time they need to
essentially leave now the other part of
this is that in response to everything
that's going on he immediately goes and
attacks the Herald right because
Stardust view is beta ray Bill's actions
as you're intervening with divinity is
really what it is right you're
intervening with the divine role of
Galactus and that's kind of why it's
interesting because it can sort of go
either way depending on who you are and
there aren't really any Galactus cults
right there aren't really any cults in
Marvel Comics and I'm aware of of people
who were just like hoping Galactus comes
to the world to consume it or like
figures out where Galactus is gonna go
next and then lands on the world to be
consumed with it but it wouldn't make
sense that there are beings out there
that view Galactus is kind of like a
divine entity because in a lot of ways
he is right he's in a central part of
the Marvel cosmology he has to exist
he's a necessity when it comes to the
cosmic abstracts that exist out there
and so with that being the case it kind
of makes sense of Stardust so basically
adopt a sort of divine perspective of
Galactus right like to defy the will of
Galactus is to like define the will of
God or to define the will of
the universe but basically what he ends
up doing here is basically taking the
entire armament avoid amp and then
channeling it down onto the planet and
then obliterates the entire planet and
this is the plan of beta ray bill his
plan is to literally follow Galactus to
every single world he's gonna go to and
destroy it before Galactus camp to
basically starve Galactus out now the
immediate question to ask here is well
then why wouldn't Galactus just destroy
him and Karen Gillan kind of plays it
fast and loose the story has some major
plot holes right I mean has some major
issues I mean the response of the
colliders is to tell the Silver Surfer
go and find that guy right like go and
find them and bring it into this so I
don't have to worry about it and any
normal circumstance Galactus if he'd
figured out what it was a beta ray bill
is gonna do probably would have just
wiped him from existence right I mean
Galactus has cosmic awareness if his
heralds came back and said okay so the
idea of beta ray bill is to destroy
every world you're gonna go to and wipe
it out before you can consume it big
Galactus would just search the space
waste for beta ray bill when he found
him bring him to him and then just
destroy him and then there's no more
problem anymore that's all there is to
it that would be the the initial
response and that's one of the reasons
why when the story came out people were
just kind of like
I don't know if I can get behind this
but it is kind of an interesting concept
right because what the even people end
up doing is traveling to a new world
they refer to as Ethan Tron a new place
of seclusion and the reason why there
could they consider themselves as
secluded people really comes to bear
when you have a fight between the silver
surfer and beta ray bill now this is
kind of something to point out here as a
over the years an in model comics
depending on what era you're talking
about characters powers can wax and wane
and they can shift but it's the nature
of things but if we were looking at like
old-school silver a silver surfer this
fight would have been over like that
like it would have been it would been
over so fast because beta ray bill never
would have stood a chance against silver
surfer if he had been like back then
right but such as it is
the fights relatively even between the
two now there also does appear to be
some holding back just because of the
fact that silver surfer is kind of like
I really don't want to kill you because
we've been friends we fought together
and that's true this story came out in
2009 and so this is after both
individuals were part of the of the oh
my god what is that group not the
invaders the not the infinites what what
is the name of that group this super
powerful superhero team um oh my god
okay Gordon do not do not do not do not
delete this all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to figure this out I'm trying
to remember I feel like people fans
watching this video just like it's this
Rob it's just like screaming into their
monitors what is the name of that team
it was gladiator we said it the other
day it was like gladiator and it was
Silver Surfer and it was Nova and it was
um it was oh my god what were they
called what was the name of that team
it's gonna drive me insane the
annihilators that's what it was
the annihilators oh my god okay cool I
got it right I thought I was gonna lose
my mind but they were both part of the
annihilators at one point right so like
and even before that they have history
together so it's not like one of these
things worse just like you're defying
the will of Galactus and our friendship
goes out the window and now you gotta
die it's nothing really like that we've
been friends like I really don't want to
fight you because you're a friend of
mine but it's kind of a cool thing
because the Silver Surfer tries to
reason with beta ray bill yeah and even
says like I understand loss I understand
what you're coming from right the
actions of Galactus led to the total
annihilation of your people I understand
where that's from believe me
very few people better than me
understand that but the response of beta
ray bill is I don't care and so as a
result of that scuttlebutt ends up
launching
or at least sort of Maki Silver Surfer
out temporarily which gives Bader a
build the ability to hop on board and
then race to a twosie thermtron
basically up to even prime and then
catch up with Galactus before early skid
there before Galactus intends to to
consume the world and so when beta ray
bill arrives there he immediately starts
talking to the Ethan people that's what
we learned what was going on right so
they are in exceedingly old race they're
by no means the oldest but they're in
exceedingly old race and like most races
most most cultures that existed out
there they initially were like a really
primitive and waged war over stupid
things and so the result of that is
eventually they rose to a point where
they realize how dumb all of this was
and ended up basically removing and
really kind of altering their very
nature so that their desire was to
basically become secluded to eliminate
their warrior prospects and then in turn
become a peaceful race that really focus
on space exploration the result of that
is that in everything that's gone on
what they've done is they've kind of tap
back into their warrior side again and
the responsibiiity ray bill is you don't
want to do this right like I get you
guys want to fight I get do you guys
wanna fend off against the forces of
Galactus and his Herald's but understand
this you guys need to leave the planet
you guys have to leave this place if you
stay here you're going to die you have
neither the ability nor the power to
destroy or even get Galactus to leave
right because sometimes it's not really
eating up even about destroying Galactus
it's about making him making his
conquest of your world more trouble than
it's worth right up is one of these
things works like okay it's a pain in
the ass to basically consume your world
I'm gonna go somewhere else right that's
if you can do that which is basically
what earth is done multiple times then
Galactus will just go elsewhere but his
response is you're not even powerful
enough to do that right I mean you guys
are ants and in the in the eyes of this
you know cosmic entity there's nothing
you can do and so void Ian ends up
chiming in for a moment and then when he
does you end up picking up the next
morning with beta ray bill coming out
and having infected the entirety of this
population where this kind of nanovirus
basically says but this is a cure that I
have here at my side leave this world
and only then will you get this cure now
this is pretty intense and is pretty
crappy right the idea that he's
basically blackmailing these people now
in the end a beta ray bill is doing it
because he believes he's doing the right
thing the question is is he actually
doing the right and the honorable thing
what is that actually the right thing to
do the culture ultimately does flee they
do end up leaving they're leaving their
plan they do end up evacuating and beta
ray bill destroys the world but the
measurement as to whether or not he's
doing something this honorable comes
when he goes to pick up storm breaker
he can't he loses the ability to lift
his own hammer basically he's fallen
down the path of a villain that's really
what this is right it's not really about
what he's done it's the path that he's
on leading to what he will do and that's
what makes this matter so much because
what we end up doing is jumping forward
by it by a short period of time and
Galactus is almost knocking on death's
door right he's not really been able to
consume any kind of life energy his
energies itself are already running
exceedingly low and so as a results that
we end up learning that of course the
the forces of the Z that are kind of
bulking up right like one half of the
group is maintaining its somewhat
secluded nature in the other half are
marshaling their forces all for the
purpose of tracking down and destroying
Galactus while all that's been going on
beta ray bill has been tracking them
everywhere they go every time they go to
a new world beta ray bill is right
behind I mean he destroys it before they
can consume it right every single time
without fail and so ultimately the life
does kind of pull Silver Surfer aside
and says here's what we're gonna do and
so you know having Silver Surfer who
shows up goes to this kind of unexplored
system where there's really nothing
there and then kind of call the sort of
Harlech with beta ray bill and says
here's what's going on man like Galactus
the reason why he's doing this is
because you know one he has to it's the
role he plays he doesn't want to he
hates it as much as anybody else does do
not be mad at him for him for doing what
he does it's like being angry -
rainstorm right it's just the natural
order of things but at the end of the
day beta ray bill does not care it
doesn't matter to him right it's kind of
like this is my vendetta against
Galactus I'm going to starve him out
this is the price he pays for destroying
my people and countless other people
across the cosmos at the same time does
Ethan people basically start marshalling
all their forces together right and when
they do they kind of have this this
insanely vast Armada right because what
we end up learning is that they never
really destroyed their systems of
weapons manufacturing right the weapons
they had the giant space station they
had they never got rid of it but it was
all still there the result here is that
they really just kind of like dug it all
back up and then in turn went back out
and and they've kind of been tracking or
have been looking for Galactus ever
since right so it's an astronomically
massive force and so what they do when
they finally tracked down Galactus they
immediately go and start launching their
attacks and initially you end up having
the various heroes who were here who are
trying to defend things off as best as
they possibly can but at the end of the
day none of it really seems to make a
difference and the reason why is because
what you end up having is this massive
kind of device that's basically used by
this by these forces to basically blast
right to kind of blast him repeatedly
and ultimately try to destroy him due to
him being so incredibly weak but what
beta ray bill basically comes to
understand here is if he really is funny
he gets entropy here well he might as
well be fighting the universe that's
really what it is he's fighting a role
he's fighting a concept he's fighting an
ideology which you can never really
succeed in doing and so understanding
this and coming to this realization that
really it has all been for naught that
he really has kind of lost his way that
ultimately he ends up sunny against
Galactus but as a cyborg what he does is
he basically tells his ship to basically
unlatch it but let him go do his thing
and what this means if it is it'll
essentially allow beta ray bill it kind
of pushes power to the extreme and
basically you know almost something akin
to like self destruct which is really
kind of the idea here right to allow all
these forces to bombard down on on
Galactus and then in turn when that
happens the energy is a beta ray bill
combined with the energy of these
explosions allows Galactus to basically
feed on the immediate area and when he
does he's right back at his full
strength and then immediately
incinerates all the Athan penal right
they're all just like gone destroyed
dead and that's basically it and then
from there you get this really amazing
conversation between Galactus and beta
ray bill and under any normal
circumstance Galactus would have just
incinerated this guy but the question is
I need to know why this guy was doing
this in the first place and beta ray
bill basically says because you destroy
the last of my people you'll never
understand what it's like to basically
be the last of your people to know that
everything that you know and love has
been totally obliterated now beta ray
bill doesn't know the story of Galactus
right and that's where the story gets
relatable right because people usually
have a tendency to do that people kind
of jump to conclusions and then never
take the time to understand the other
side right so they kind of assume they
understand they have all the facts
when they never really had them all in
the first place right in that kind of
arrogance hubris it's really what what
beta ray bill was operating with right
he was operating under the assumption
that Galactus was just some malevolent
force going out there and just
destroying all things that he was
operating under emotion right he was
just angry he was upset you know and
that kind of a thing and beings get
stupid when we get emotional and so
Galactus really chimes in and says no I
understand exactly where you're coming
from I can never recreate my own people
I can never recreate the world that I
come from because it would create an
imbalance if Galactus did that say for
example that he recreated his people on
some world out there that he would
create an imbalance of the universe
Livie tribunal steps in and says destroy
that or I destroy you so Galactus would
not only have a momentary moan
momentary version of happiness but he
would lose it all at the same time even
if he could he could never be a part of
that world he hungers for all eternity
for her from now until the end of the
universe
he will hunger and have to consume
life-sustaining world's so even if he
did recreate that it would be like
Superman in the bottle city of idle city
of Kandor he can never really be a part
of it and so because that is kind of
this torment of Galactus that he can
never go back to the way things used to
be but what he tells beta ray bill is
your people are not completely dead
right everything that dies becomes part
of a greater whole their essences still
exist out there and so what he ends up
doing is basically recreating one of the
members of beta ray Bill's group right
and basically brings her in and when
beta ray bill shows back up on the peak
to meet back up with sword he of course
tells Abigail brand this is a TA Toa
rock you guys probably remember her as
the chick that that Peter quill was
flirting with and guardians of the
galaxy so she's in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
she's just not a korbinite but she's
brought in by beta ray bill and it's the
idea that the two of them working
together can kind of repopulate the
korbinite population it doesn't happen
but they could have it gets kind of
weird I think she's around for like a
little while and then she dies and like
one of the journey into mystery stories
I think oh she's not really important
and I don't think you ever really see
her again it's kind of weird anyway ah
yes that's the story be rebuild god
Hunter I thought it was pretty cool I
always thought it was an interesting
story there's definitely some weak
points in there there's some potholes
which I'm sure a lot of you guys will
probably point out but it was it was
cool like I I enjoyed it I thought it
was kind of interesting but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comets explain to make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
Bruce okay I want to give a shout out to
Kyle B David Joseph Ben john h aj matt
in jeff our john h lean and mean which
is an awesome name jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K
and Genesis 9:6 team remember guys you
could send me messages and I'll run off
whatever your message is at the end of
the video so long as there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at rubber
Jefferson comm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]
[Music]